I have been married to a lovely man for
15 years who loves me and adores my son
he is the best dad I could have given to
my son the problem is the finances I
make
$180,000 as a nurse practitioner while
he makes 30,000 the issue is not really
the money but his lack of ambition to
make more of it he has so much potential
I recently found him a job which will
double his salary but he's just not
interested how do I love my husband the
way he is since he refuses to change
number one I'm glad that you just that
you realize you can't control him
because you can't we can't control other
people and the fact that it sounds like
you're his mom I'm like you went out and
found him a job and you're doing all of
these things you're being proactive
while he's obviously not wanting it so
so I would say again the money is not
the issue here a lot of it is fear that
if something happens are are are you
going to be okay is your family going to
be okay and so that's the approach I
would take with him not oh go double
your salary